a bunch of tacos what the heck is
directed and picked cool camera angles
you can be a director reasonably telling
with guns there and not get shot by the
LAPD let's say I want to get into the
movie business
alright how do I do it dude here's what
you do this is this is dude Wat Pho dude
produced rush that battlefield like we
did it for the rush did you produce the
lifeline the interpreter is amazing can
you smell what The Rock's cooking and
you just finished his first-ever
directorial debut called the incantation
is a horror movie but it's thriller hard
and fantasy all mixed it a little bit of
Super Bowl the reason Judas hairs
because Jude is a bonafide experienced
Hollywood producer who's made films of
all types all varieties all sizes yes
and he has lots of war stories and
interesting tidbits and tips and facts
all his grades and things to share with
you Iceland what the heck is directing
let's say I want to get into the movie
business all right how do I do that Jude
what what most people not know about
being a producer a director though how
do you know when to say no to something
creative versus something would you say
yes does the director find a producer to
find the director I used to think like
all the abstract paintings are really
dumb took some classes on something I
learned about the context in the history
and what goes into this something the
paintings become much more admirable and
you can respect them and you can
understand them you get a deeper
understanding in the art and hopefully
through a interviews like this I'm
talking Jude you guys are getting a
little bit deeper understanding and more
appreciation out of your movies we're
trying to make your movies better
yeah dude what is that you do producing
is like being the main jefe in charge
again and
if you owned a restaurant for example
not only are you probably have a good
callin air background under the chef but
you also have to manage your employees
you have to manage the things they're
coming in and all the supplies and the
truck drivers that show up and people
that open up the people that clean in
all that so it's like so much stuff so
that's basically what a producer does
like we do everything we handle
everyone's individual needs and wants
the logistics of the production the
money part all the executives that think
they're better than everybody it's a
combination of all that stuff it does
change movie by movie because of
politics I always picture I always go
back to like woman that one runs the
social club at the church because she
it's her little world and she has the
power she's like no I said no vanilla
cupcakes to the bazaars like that so
like you have that church lady in every
film you might have five of those church
ladies so you have to appease them
because if they work for X brand or X
network or X studio they're in power
there even though you like for example I
have 25 years plus experience but still
I can't go in there and say hey this is
how we've been doing it since the
Cupertino vanilla okay Kent Kings I told
you and we should find someplace to park
if somebody comes in yells at us we'll
move the car so you direct it for your
first time again
like it maybe do um didn't like any
commercial directing or short directing
that's like you're very fishy on paper
it's definitely my directorial debut
Iceland what the heck is directing what
is directing directing directing is
madness is what it is as you know your
director as well to me the main thing
about directing is the Shah this is the
most important thing that you're playing
the movie back over and over in your
head and you're hoping it works and you
you can see of course you have your
vision that's what everybody calls it
but is the physical thing that you see
is this box exactly the way that I
pictured it in my mind and often times
it's not and that's part of the whole
process that's one aspect the other
aspect is of course getting into the
actors heads right that's really hard to
do and and then of course the logistic
that creeps in which is why you gotta
have a good producer but it always
creeps in because we hear a director you
have to make a decision you kind of have
to have both hats a little bit but being
director you you want to be like 90
percent focused on between today Nikko
and I are location scouting for urban
Zelda this location needs to be kind of
a grungy looking location to fit the
whole sci-fi post-apocalyptic vibe that
we're going for it's getting harder and
harder to find locations in LA Hunter
Street we recycled he knew so many times
but even hundred streets becoming
difficult to shoot I mean look at it
right now it's kind of its kind of busy
so we can't really shoot here we're
gonna be scouting Los Angeles looking
for a street that is open enough and
quiet enough for us to shoot there what
else do you think usually bill filming
with guns they're not get shot by the
LAPD that's a big one
Julie are all the time I mean ideally
this right here is perfect what about
them they're in there we could do it
everyone I don't know what it was
obviously it's really loud because we
are currently under a freeway so it's
not gonna be great for sound but
aesthetically it looks perfect beautiful
I mean if you look up you got like some
nice concrete on the ground
what we need to do there's enough
barricades and whatnot
this would be ideal honest
I really like what I'm seeing here
there's a video of these guys filming a
bank robbery scene in southern city the
cops are called because some I think
there's a bank robbery actually
happening and one of the actors steps
out the door with his fake gun and that
cop fires a shot at him thought of like
reflex as it gets scared this guy having
a gun which is totally reasonable
thankfully he misses doesn't hit the guy
the guys like well it's a big gun it's
like now dude you get down on the ground
the cops tell you to get down on the
ground
you worry about your innocence in court
we don't want that to happen here if you
brandishing fake guns people call the
cops thing you have real guns then you
then you've done in most of these you'd
call dispatch and tell them what's going
on
so people called the police either
dispatch you know the police could
explain what's happening police wouldn't
freak out they wouldn't come get you
here it's a little bit different and
that you don't want to have that even
happen in the first place you don't want
anybody calling the cops so you have to
make sure you've communicated to
everybody around here that you're
filming you have to make sure that it's
visibly clear that you're filming you
know that cop walking with the bank
having the actors step out to the street
an uncontrolled environment with no
production assistance onset no signs no
crew he just steps on the street with a
fake gun that's dumb
and that's what you can't do here so if
you have a guy with a gun he makes you
have the crew yet the cameras you have
signs mean from the neighbors etc so no
one calls the cops
thinking that there's a robbery going up
the end of the day I think location wise
I think we have a good three options we
have really good options so what would
what most people not know about being a
producer a director though are some
things I like you generally wouldn't
guess the
I think Oh important thing that people
don't know is that you have to be a real
people person and that's something
because you see the glamor and Hollywood
and people think of the red carpet and
think all these if you just have a
creative mind you can pick cool camera
angles you can be a director it's way
more but a lot of it's working with
people because you got to work with the
DP with your keys some of the actors are
really emotional because they get paid
to be emotional so even in their private
lives they're just like all over the
place so you have to take all these
different types of people and get them
to get on the same page the script page
and see your vision and and mold them
into this and you got to be a leader I
don't know if people think that they
need to manage people so now you've seen
both sides of it how do you know one
just say no to something creative versus
some would you say yes put the money on
the screen usually new directors get in
there and they're like oh I need to have
whatever
have a super techno crane and I even
have all these crazy things which you
don't really need obviously you've read
the scripts that your producer your
though from the beginning
you know the story you know the
important piece to hit and the important
creative to hit so you can kind of Judge
a director to right away and be like
okay this guy gets it and he knows
what's gonna be great and what's just
toys for Toys sake which is not a good
thing does the director find a producer
or does there find the director the
question is what comes first the chicken
or the egg well normally on project it's
the producers so normally some of all on
the rights to it a studio or whoever a
financier will get behind it and they'll
say okay we want to make this project
who's a good director and then they'll
think of directors who fit in this style
or maybe who are up-and-coming or trendy
and they'll say let's go ahead for that
guy the money has to come first we got a
bunch of tacos my beef tacos these are
the idle ones okay well I started in the
business basically getting the popular
mountain PA and production assistant and
making phone calls and stuff like the
first one I ever did was probably one of
the biggest it was called bison Te'o man
with Robin Williams and it was like 125
million bucks which back then was huge
now that's not really that big with all
the Marvel movies and stuff so I did
that and then I gotten rid of the wing
of some people at Fox so I started
working with a bunch of Fox stuff so so
I'd have to look at my cuz that they all
blend in the other ones that promise
gonna have Jude all talking yeah the
cameras being shaky is this Carmichael
you know you couldn't just stop filming
this part you know good
I got thousands after this Monday we're
shooting in three days just coming out
of here right now to take some quick
shots using the ring that we'll be using
them or shooting that little piece just
want to get a feel for you know how
sunlight looks we're in the sunlight
hitting just getting an overall idea of
like what I can use that when I go back
into the office I can create a lot in
put this lot into the camera that way on
the day of having a very clear idea of
what I'm getting the success of your
short film whatever project that you're
doing is highly highly highly correlated
to the amount of prep work that you do
there will always int you always we
unknown variables that will pop off on a
film shoot and it is up to you to figure
out how to navigate those unknown
variables but if you have let's just say
90% of your script figured out on how
you're going to engage that that project
you will have a better outcome I
guarantee you
yeah like already I'm noticing this side
of the picture right here decided that
the location is dark
because it's bright sunlight I'm gonna
be on this side of the line meaning I'm
gonna be shooting mostly that way I'm
not gonna be shooting just everything's
gonna be blown out so I already made
that decision cell so this is much more
appealing to the eye like you have so
much going on with these concrete slabs
they're like that
I'm noticing right now our cars might be
an issue we do not control these cars we
do not have this location lock down so
that's gonna be a continuity issue I
know that but there's nothing
high school I started making these
facility like movies my friends and
that's kind of where I learned like oh
man I better actually I can't just show
up the best lessons comes from mistakes
I've learned the most more so than I
have done in film school by making
mistakes on my own shoots nice you
probably ought to get into filmmaking or
thought about getting into filmmaking or
know somebody was wanting to get into
filmmaking let's say I want to get into
the movie business
alright how do I do it dude here's what
you do you quit your job you leave your
family I'm scared you know here's what
you do it's all about connections we're
talking to earlier Carmichael and myself
about how nowadays resume is not as big
as thing as ethics and personality and
people liking you that's what it's about
so about people liking you I get emails
constantly in messages people going how
do I get in the business I want to do
this I want to do this and I say well
you got to get involved with whatever
you have access to that could be a
community theater it could be high
school
I'm sure there's ten people that you
know right now that are making insurance
help those guys out work with them see
if you like the industry first because a
lot of people have this glamorous idea
of what the film business is all about
they don't realize that it's no sleep
and a lot of hard work and a lot of
stress get some experience under your
belt or grab your camera grab your
iPhone and go out there to start filming
stuff that's how you guys get started
just cut some stuff together make some
stuff to get a more professional gloss
on your stuff everyone does that it's a
it's a craft to do that work with
anybody and don't don't be below it
that's the thing that really bugs me
when people go like like I want to be an
actor I want to be Leonardo DiCaprio or
Brad Pitt but they're like yeah I don't
do that George
I don't do theater work well screw you
because you have to do that you have to
get that experience 46 years old just
recently I was an extra on the good
place once you get into it whether it's
your theater production or your high
school or college or a professional
movie set is the buddy are just a buddy
be cool show up show up early work hard
like make friends be professional and
they'll remember you and they'll call me
back that's what happened to me I did
like a hundred different jobs and I just
had this personality and I kept people
were like hey call a guy dude like he'll
do it and then some people would say
okay can you do this I'd be like no but
I I can try and I'll do really good at
and I'll learn how to do it I said cool
that alone makes me want to hire you so
come on try it and see if you can do it
and then I would the easiest way to
network is to love what you're doing
find other people that love what they're
doing and just do it and don't worry
about getting paid because if you're
looking to get paid not have as many
opportunities yeah yeah just go out
there and start doing it and ideally
you're doing it because you love it I do
it's not a garage
and not get paid and yeah I know and she
competed a few work but the reality is
we're starting out and kind of suck so
you got and you do it and you make
friends and you find other people are
passionate about it and once you do that
long enough somebody gets a job
something gets a gig y'all throwing
together and get calling and anybody can
do it anything else in life you want to
do you can actually do it if you stay
focused I would say when you get in the
industry at first it's like college like
picking your major right here like home
and I really like literature but I like
theater get the basics down you should
pre Ilion start to learn what it is you
want to do you know maybe it takes you a
year or two that's fine just like a
college degree you may not know your
freshman year but eventually say okay I
do want to be a director of photography
or I do want to be a director or I do
want to be an actor because those are
different paths different styles and
different skill sets to have if you get
a reputation for getting things done
yeah people start to depend on you when
people start to depend on you you
probably find yourself in a position of
leadership absolutely I've heard a
position of leadership you're in a
position of values that's better yeah
well back in the studio yeah let's do it
I want to know truth yes what's the most
expensive shot you've ever had to or to
make happen the most expensive shot I
ever did was a Korean movie that I shot
in Thailand
called sunny six hundred extras just
like soldiers with full military gear
that means guns six hundred guns six
hundred helmets six every day two years
all of that stuff all period in mind you
as well but here's the kicker we had
imagined the permits for this and people
need to be around three helicopters
airborne at
within the size of a probably a soccer
field though you got some safety issues
you got permission issues you got air
space you got pilots you got extras you
got actors and you probably had on that
show about 250 crew members in that
hangs up an amazing like fuel for the
help fuel for the helicopters and all
that so it gives some links or anything
on that know that we didn't but uh Oh
actually yeah yeah there was explosions
assume that's the whole pie right I
forgot
that's that Oh basically in that scene
you have a woman who's looking for a
husband in the Vietnam War and these
helicopters are taking off and it's like
a field unit where they what's dying in
their arm it will not see had special
effects and all that and she runs out to
a helicopter and she jumps on she's like
take me to my husband then I get out of
here in the military and she's oh yeah
so that was basically it
and that shot probably let me do some
quick math you did three huh
I would say that shot alone probably
cost in the realm of three hundred
thousand dollars for that shot so I just
like out so you guys just took a house
and they go that shot that shot was
probably two minutes all right we're
back in the studio from lunch I've
learned a bunch my brain is heavier
thanks to a rapping right there
but Jude's movie is out yeah the 31st of
July might be when you're seeing this
right now I'm not sure go check it out
on where I really need your guy's help
because this is me just like these guys
got their start from the ground up so
did I I put all my effort into this go
check it out on iTunes we're gonna put
the link down there for you call the
incantation it's starting former
Superman Dean Cain you'll see my ugly
mug in there acting too so make fun of
me all you want
now why iTunes there's a million ways
you can put this video out there yeah it
is other places it's all over Red Box
family video Amazon all that stuff
iTunes the one that it'll help me
because if you guys click on it for
example it'll get featured on their home
page and then if it's favored it'll go
up in the corner and then they might
hold it for a month and then we're all
happy I'm coming here cuz you're
subscribing
oh do you have questions for Jude yeah
whatever you want throw em in the
comments below if we get a bunch we'll
do a follow up will come back go to
lunch again
and yeah answer home much more juicy
question each one of these gray hairs
was earned on a film says I got your
back appreciate brother you bet